[Music]
ideas of the science of religion are
complicated God is difficult to bring
into the laboratory and it is very hard
to quantify the sacred but science is
beginning to ask questions about the
results or the consequences of
participating in religious life
questions like does participating in a
religious community does having faith in
God does engaging in a process of
building a relationship with the divine
do those questions add positivity to
people's lives and the research is
conclusive and the research shows that
yes a person who participates in a faith
community who has a relationship with
God and it was on a quest for purpose
that their lives are better and that
they do scale higher in the tests of
well-being and happiness does that mean
it is because as they engage in a
process of discovering their faith and
deepening their relationship with God
that it is reciprocated on high I don't
know that is very hard to quantify but
what we do know is that people who
participate actively in faith community
they have a higher standard of health
and that might be because within
religious communities in the best case
scenario the teachings and the wisdom
and the practices are about things like
family personal responsibility making a
positive impact in the world helping
others deepening relationships and all
of those practices do it had positive
value to a person's life and so the
reactions are the consequences for
participating in faith community do add
positive value and well-being and life
satisfaction to people's lives positive
psychology got its start from the
awareness that the field was focused too
much on people
weaknesses and not their strengths and
so Martin Seligman and Chris Peterson
worked to shift the way psychology is
practiced rather than think of someone
and their problems we think of someone
and their strengths and we try to
develop those strengths try to see the
best in people because everybody has
signature strengths and we want to focus
and help them develop those and in
developing those it helps to shore up
some of their weaknesses in a communal
setting expanding on the inventory we
try to apply the same characteristics
that are articulated for individuals but
we try to put them into practice in a
communal setting and in a communal
setting is where Judaism lends itself
beautifully to applying the inventory of
strengths and characteristics so the
intersection of where positive
psychology and the science of happiness
intersect with positive religion and
positive Judaism really live at the
intersection of perma perma is an
acronym which stands for positive
emotion engagement relationships meaning
and accomplishment so let's take each of
these five domains and see them in the
context of religious practice so we'll
start with P positive emotion in a
best-case scenario you think about a
sanctuary or amphitheater setting where
faith communities gather and there are
messages of hope there are soothing
melodies there's good music
there's fellowship and all of those
combined together are designed to raise
the positive emotion in someone's life
and I can tell you that when I travel I
go to different churches synagogues
mosques over the summer I was in Iceland
and I went to an Episcopal Church in
Reykjavik where the entire ceremony was
spoken in Iceland
dick and I didn't understand a word but
over the course of an hour and a half I
felt my energy level shift and I walked
out of that Chapel feeling more positive
and it has to do with the environment so
positive emotions are raised by
participating in faith community next
engagement well the best religions are
about helping people to engage in the
world an engagement happens in engaging
in relationships engaging in study
engaging in work engaging in the process
hopefully of making our world a better
place those tend to be key themes in
religious life an engagement has been
shown to add positive value to a person
in life next relationships well
relationships are at the heart of most
faith communities it is about bringing
people together
it is about caring for people it is
about having relationships with fellow
congregants clergy educators and
relationship with text in relationship
with God those are all elements of
relationships that add value to a
person's life when they are expressed in
authentic ways then we have a meaning so
many people are in search of meaning in
the 21st century and wisdom literature
the content of great religions are all
designed to help people discover the
meaning and the purpose in their lives
and finally accomplishment
accomplishment is one of the core
teachings that come out of good
religious practices the accomplishment
of making the world a better place now
that has a core teaching in Judaism the
idea of tikkun olam repairing the world
and making it a better place and having
that as a goal to accomplish both for
individuals and as a collective
religious community all that combined
together in perma
seems to be the perfect application of
this theory of positive psychology and
religious settings I believe are that
perfect application that perfect place
to see and to live the theory of perma
and positive psychology now there's more
than just perma and positive judaism and
positive religion there's also a studied
set of characteristics and strengths
that come directly from the work of
Martin Seligman and Chris Peterson who
in the 1990s developed an inventory of
strengths there have been some changes
to this inventory but in a nutshell it
has codified 24 different personality
strengths like gratitude resilience hope
optimism bravery spirituality goodness
kindness and others and the idea is that
each person has signature strengths but
understood in the context of the larger
inventory people can see where they fit
into the scale and can attempt to
develop other areas of strengths to help
improve the quality of their lives so in
the practice of positive Judaism we take
that inventory very seriously and when
we think about religious practice we
draw on those strengths in our teachings
and the way in which we shape
experiences for people's religious
engagement
[Music]